aaron siegel better known to foundation
members as 05-1 descends into the abyss
of a deepwall site he exits the elevator
and peers into the optical scanner to
unlock the reinforced door inside the
room is mobile task force tau5 samsara
aaron siegel refers to these immortal
cyborg clones created from the flesh of
a dead god as his red right hand your
mission is to eliminate the traitor 05-4
and to find the insurgents who have been
killing the members of the overseer
council the cyborgs stand at attention
now aaron siegel screams the soldiers of
the red right hand march out the door to
start their mission aaron siegel pauses
for a moment and then slams his fist
against the wall in frustration he has
lost nine overseers to calvin lucian and
his kill squad team they have been
somehow overcoming the odds each time
and eliminating each overseer they
tracked down it wasn't supposed to end
this way aaron siegel vows to kill them
all calvin lucian meanwhile sits on a
private jet with adam and olivia he had
just hung up the phone after a
conversation with 05-4 the overseer
known as the ambassador wants to
surrender to the insurgency there's a
good chance this is a trap but calvin
has decided to meet with the ambassador
all the same calvin drops off adam and
olivia at an insurgency base they still
haven't fully recovered from the
previous mission with 05-5 known as the
blackbird before leaving though calvin
meets with an insurgency agent named
sylvester sloan who is going to join him
as support calvin says goodbye to adam
and olivia then leaves with sloan to
meet the ambassador in south africa
after landing at johannesburg airport
calvin and sloane disembark and are led
to a conference room where the
ambassador sits waiting for them calvin
and sloane sit across from mo 5-4 to
discuss his surrender the council is in
shambles says the ambassador everything
is falling apart i want to offer my
services and information to the
insurgency in exchange for protection
from o5-1 he has lost his mind calvin
agrees to the terms and prepares for
extraction but as they get up from the
table gunshots can be heard from down
the hall the ambassador's eyes open wide
in terror it's too late he whispers
calvin and sloan grab the ambassador who
is frozen in fear and exit the
conference room they make their way
towards their plane but the gunshots are
getting closer calvin looks over his
shoulder to see samsara pursuing them
through the terminal calvin shoves the
ambassador behind a table as bullets
whiz overhead calvin and sloane return
fire but their volley doesn't seem to
slow down the assassins calvin and sloan
pull the ambassador to his feet and they
burst through an emergency exit onto the
sun-baked tarmac where they make a mad
dash for the plane from behind them a
bullet rips through the chest of sloan
the red right hand has caught up but
calvin continues to drag the ambassador
towards the plane they are almost there
suddenly a metallic child's voice blares
through the airport's external speakers
the child's voice says i want calvin
lucien alive i have business to settle
with him the red right-hand soldiers
tackle calvin and the ambassador to the
ground when they are just feet away from
the plane kill the traitor the child's
voice says and calvin can only watch
helplessly as the ambassador is
violently murdered one of the agents
turns towards calvin and slams his fist
into calvin's face causing him to
blackout calvin awakes in a dark room he
is unsure how much time has passed the
only light in the room comes from a
screen on the wall in the middle of the
screen is a rotating red scp foundation
seal a voice from a speaker speaks hello
calvin lucian my name is the kid i am
the third overseer you have killed all
my friends and now i will kill all of
yours the door to the room opens calvin
leans through the doorway there is a
long dimly lit hallway the kid orders
him to proceed so they can meet face to
face as calvin walks the kid's voice
echoes down the hallway there once was
another 05-3 he built incredible
machines even one that could see into
the future but unfortunately for him he
did not have the passion required to be
an overseer that was when i was
born i was chosen by the other overseers
to have my spinal cord severed in a way
that gave me the ability of the
all-seeing eye i now watch everything
all of the time i have perfect reasoning
perfect awareness and perfect
understanding calvin gets to the end of
the corridor which opens up into a large
chamber tied up in the middle of the
room are olivia and adam calvin runs to
his friends and crouches down next to
them a mechanical suit stands on a
platform looking down at calvin olivia
and adam calvin realizes the kid must be
contained inside i now sentence you all
to death the mechanical suit says as the
red right hand steps out of the shadows
and slowly walks towards the remaining
members of the kill squad suddenly there
is a flash of light and the black queen
appears stop what are you doing shriek's
the kid the black queen hands calvin the
interdimensional rod and reel he used to
defeat the blackbird calvin casts the
rod from out of the terror in space
comes a massive multi-armed creature
known as maladramigion the red right
hand engages the monster trying to force
it back into its dimension but the
monster is too powerful he grabs the
cyborg clones and pulls them through the
terror in reality as samsara battles the
melodrama kion calvin frees olivia and
adam they make a run for the door but as
they flee one of the walls opens up to
reveal a turing the gun fires and a
bullet hits olivia directly in the head
killing her instantly no yells calvin
before calvin can push adam out of the
way a second bullet from the turret
launches itself and adam's back calvin
and adam slide across the floor the kid
in his mechanical suit jumps down from
the platform above i'm going to kill you
now calvin lucien he says in his
mechanical voice there is another flash
of light calvin watches in front of him
as the spear of the non-believer
manifests itself before his eyes galvan
grabs the spear and shoves it into the
kid's machine body it easily penetrates
the armor and pins him to the wall
calvin walks up to the exoskeleton and
tears off the outer plating revealing a
tank full of fluid within which floats a
malformed human fetus as calvin finally
looks upon the kid's true form he hears
the sound of mocking mechanical laughter
calvin breaks the glass and crushes the
kid with his bare hands as calvin turns
from the now silent robotic body of the
kid the room begins to shame debris is
raining down from above calvin helps
adam up and puts olivia's lifeless body
across his shoulders what remains of the
kill squad makes their way out of the
kid's lair outside of the foundation
side where they were being held calvin
helps adam lie down on the ground before
gently setting olivia's body next to him
adam grimaces as blood pours out of the
wound in his back calvin reaches into
his pocket and pulls out the vial of
water from the fountain of youth there
are only a couple of drops left which he
pours into adam's mouth adam looks up at
calvin tears filling his eyes he
whispers i love you before he passes out
from the pain the wound in his back
begins to heal instantly and calvin
calls an insurgency evac team to come
pick up adam with adam safe calvin picks
up olivia and walks alone towards a
truck in the lot outside of the
foundation site he needs to finish this
once and for all he will kill the last
two overseers or he will die trying 05-1
aaron siegel arrives at where the tigris
and euphrates rivers meet the garden of
eden he is in a frenzy due to the
assassinations of all the other
overseers besides himself and the
nazarene and nothing will stop him as he
approaches the gate to the garden of
eden though he is stopped by the
guardian of the garden a massive
powerful anomalous entity with a flaming
sword but aaron siegel has no time or
patience for anything to get in his way
even something as powerful as the gate
guardian the guardian swings his burning
sword at adam who rolls out of the way
and in a flash takes out a scranton
reality anchor he slams the anchor into
the ground which causes the world to
shimmer and riffle around him he watches
as the flames from the gate guardian
sword seem to absorb back into its body
before it shrinks down looking to fold
in on itself until all that is left is a
charred skeleton with the guardian
defeated aaron sprints into the garden
he searches the garden for 05-2 but
can't find her anywhere he finally comes
to the tree of life and that's where he
finds her laying at the base of the tree
in a pool of blood is the nazarene she
has taken her own life
this is her anomalous power though she
has died many times before yet death
always spared her and brought her back
but somehow he knows this time is final
aaron drops to his knees and screams in
frustration for all the power aaron
siegel possesses there's nothing he can
do now he sits next to the nazarene's
body for hours hoping that she might
wake up or that he will to find that
this was all a dream after sitting next
to her cold body for some time he
notices something in her snowy white
hand it's a no in it the nazarene
explains that she was the one who gave
the vials from the fountain to calvin
lucian and that she is the one who made
the spear appear before him that he used
to kill the kid she explained that while
she died many times and death always
brought her back each time she felt less
and less like herself less and less like
dr sophia light she hoped that maybe if
things ended up like this it would give
aaron the chance to walk away and live
the life that they might have been able
to have together but she knows deep down
that aaron's fade is to meet calvin and
finish things once and for all aaron
siegel screams and rage clutching the
node in his hand he tries to summon
death but no one comes aaron siegel is
alone he stands up and walks deeper into
the garden he walks until he reaches a
spot where even god's light does not
reach in this desolate land is an impact
crater where lucifer star of the morning
had fallen
in the middle of the crater lies
lucifer's sword aaron siegel descends
into the hole and picks up the sword he
turns and exits the garden of eden aaron
siegel has only one mission in life now
to kill
calvin lucian calvin reads the final
entry of the journal in it the author
warns that although he hopes the
information contained within the journal
is helpful he hopes the reader does not
try to use it the words written on the
final page are this information will
only lead you to a devastating end
calvin closes the journal and looks up
at the structure in front of him he has
made it to scythe-01 he had left
olivia's body in a cave nearby promising
to her that he would make this right he
now walks up to the massive doors and
places his hand on the knotted wood the
doors slowly creak open calvin pauses
for a moment and looks behind him at the
setting sun he enters site-01 where he
knows 05-1 is where aaron siegel waits
inside the main hall calvin sees a giant
doorway in the shape of the scp
foundation seal with artistic depictions
of certain scps that he instinctively
knows are special in some way standing
next to the doorway is a two meter tall
man in what looks to be a futuristic
suit calvin approaches and asks who this
giant man is he responds that his name
is purpose the red right hand he is the
guardian of o5-1 and none shall enter
the sanctum until he returns he isn't
here ask calvin no purpose responds he
is and with that he steps aside and lets
calvin pass through the doorway the
doorway leads into a large room where
screens on the wall flash to life
depicting moments from calvin's journey
documenting his entire quest had he been
in control at all or was this all a
setup to lead him to this moment as he
walks forward he finally sees him
sitting at a table in the middle of the
room is aaron siegel euro 5-1 calvin
asks aaron the man responds my name is
aaron galvin asks about the location of
the second overseer the nazarene but
05-1 doesn't respond
without needing any more information
calvin pulls out his sidearm and in a
flash fires off five shots the bullets
stopped in the air inches from aaron
before dissolving in a flash of light
calvin should have known it wouldn't be
this easy stand up aaron siegel calvin
calls up as he holsters his gun let's
finish it calvin pulled the spear of the
non-believer from his back but aaron's
only response was to laugh
you don't even know why you're here
aaron said calvin calls back i'm here to
kill you because when i do i kill the
foundation because when you're gone the
universe can finally heal you're like me
calvin lucian we are both men driven by
our own convictions regardless of the
outcome it would seem fate has brought
us together now either your convictions
will be broken or you will die says
aaron siegel he then draws lucifer's
flaming sword and lunges towards calvin
lucian as the two men clash with one
another their supernatural weapons begin
to destroy the room around them
furniture is shattered video screens are
obliterated and fire spreads across the
walls aaron catches calvin off balance
and swings the flaming sword across
calvin's stomach calvin slides back from
the impact hunching over from the pain
in his midsection he brings his head up
to see aaron siegel running towards him
with the flaming sword high in the air
calvin brings up the spear from his
knees he leans back and launches it
towards aaron siegel the spear enters
the final overseer's chest the force
from the throw pinning him against the
wall aaron siegel drops lucifer's sword
it shatters as it hits the ground he
clutches the shaft of the spear
protruding from his sternum with both
hands 05-1 looks at calvin unbelievably
you have no idea what you've done it was
never about the overseers aaron siegel
says spitting out blood with every word
it was something deeper something worse
calvin walks slowly towards aaron siegel
he stops just in front of his final
enemy this is the way it ends calvin
says aaron siegel manages to whisper one
final word sofia before his body finally
goes lim calvin turns to see purpose
standing behind him he's dead calvin
says half to purpose in half to himself
i killed him after a moment he asks
purpose what he really wants to know
there's a room in this facility where
someone could unmake the foundation
right take me there without any
hesitation purpose leads calvin back to
the room with depictions of important
scps there purpose opens the door to an
elevator but stops calvin before he can
get inside i am duty bound to tell you
purpose says that once you step inside
this elevator there is no going back
there is only one decision to be made
and it is not one that can be unmade i
know calvin responds it's time before
stepping inside the elevator opens a
door to reveal a room filled with
bookcases and a huge window offering a
beautiful view of the sun setting behind
the mountains on the wall are monitors
depicting the ways he had killed all of
the overseers and in the middle of the
room is a large desk with a computer
calvin sits down at the desk and the
computer comes to life the computer
prompts him to scan his fingerprint
which it accepts he's logged in the
computer screen displays numerous
locations around the planet and he
quickly recognizes that they are all scp
foundation science then he sees the
single option the computer is giving him
terminate calvin reaches out with his
finger this is it once he presses this
button the scp foundation will be no
more his finger is millimeters from the
button when the phone rings calvin
hadn't even noticed that there was a
phone on the desk calvin stares at it
for a moment then picks it up hello he
says the voice on the other line
responds hello calvin lucian my name is
the administrator i've been following
your work for some time now and i must
say i am impressed i have just been
informed that you have completed your
mission congratulations are an order
what the hell are you talking about
calvin asks please listen says the voice
on the other line the man you just
killed was once in the same exact
position you are in now granted it was a
very long time ago but aaron siegel
originally was trying to destroy the
foundation that was until i convinced
him otherwise and now like aaron siegel
you will become the new head of the
foundation like how i will yells calvin
i could hang up and walk away right now
and be done with all this you could
continues the administrator but if no
one is in charge of the scp foundation
millions of people will die
if not billions and then nobody would be
there to manage what comes after there
is silence from calvin that's what i
thought says the administrator i look
forward to working with you calvin
lucian or should i say
05-1
the line goes dead
[Music]
[Music]
you